direct cette fois ci avec arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire bonsoir
anneaux benedetti d'être avec nous un
discours assez long avec une rhétorique
qui reviennent revenait plusieurs fois
nous sommes en guerre
witt une rhétorique solennelle une
rhétorique martial le président de la
république a voulu assister sur la
gravité des moments que la société est
en train de traverser
c'était si vous voulez un discours qui
d'abord cherché à justifier sa première
intervention et puis surtout a décliné
de nouvelles mesures qui sont plus
contraignantes pour l'ensemble des
françaises et des français notamment en
matière de déplacements en l'occurrence
on s'attendait plutôt à ta près tout ce
que l'on pouvait finalement voir fuité
depuis le début de la journée à des
mesures certainement beaucoup plus
encore coercitive de tweets italienne on
est dix ans sur une position qui était
intermédiaire manifestement qui n'est
pas tout à fait la position que nos
voisins italiens ont adopté mais qui
bien évidemment refaire les contraintes
sur notamment les déplacements des
françaises et des français sur les
conditions de devis de vie quotidienne
et on attend maintenant bien évidemment
parce que c'est plus important les
modalités d'application et on voit bien
que le président de la république laisse
le soin à son premier mini que
d'annoncer ses modalités d'application
vraisemblement par les heures qui
viennent
comment vous avez trouvé la tonalité
justement de discours didier maïsto
assez critique envers le président de la
république nous disait que c'était une
bonne réponse mais effectivement vous
faisiez allusion à ce confinement total
qui semblait être la solution choisie
par le gouvernement qui ne l'a
finalement pas été
pour vous c'est une demi mesure où c'est
une bonne chose peut-être de ne pas
contraintes trop les français
d'un seul coup écoutez sur un plan
sanitaire moi je ne suis pas en mesure
de vous répondre seuls les scientifiques
et les médecins sont sont capables
aujourd'hui d'apporter des réponses
au vu de ce qu'ils connaissent à la fois
du virus et de la propagation de ce
virus ce qui est sûr c'est que il a
vraisemblablement n'a pas voulu
vraisembablement prendre des mesures
hyper contraignantes qui soit 10 ont
perçu qu'on me brutale alors est ce que
c'est à la hauteur de l'épidémie ça seul
l'avenir nous le dira mais il est clair
qu'on a eu un président de la république
et une tonalité extrêmement grave encore
une fois extrêmement martial répétant à
plusieurs reprises nous sommes en guerre
certains d'ailleurs peut-être que même
cette sémantique est atteint pour
souffler au regard de situations
historiques elle était véritablement
petty 6 qu'en l'occurrence mais il a
voulu vraisemblement est et sur le fait
que nous étions dans un contexte qui
nécessité de prendre des mesures
beaucoup plus contraignante que les
premières mesures qu'il a annoncées
jeudi dernier encore une fois moi je
pense que la la la la
finalement le grand enseignement qu'il
faut retenir de ce discours surtout ces
rassemblements l'infléchissement
politique il est en train de donner à
son mandat je crois que quelque chose
d'absolument essentiel qui a été dit par
le président de la république et qui va
interroger bien évidemment les
commentateurs et des acteurs politiques
et que les réformes en cours sont
suspendues et là en effet il s'agit
d'une annonce qui pour le coup
extrêmement précise et qui est
indéniablement vient changer en tout cas
la tonte politique dans ce pays
justement renommée tijani venir
évidemment cette inflexion politique
report de beaucoup de réformes dont
celle là des retraites est une sacrée
bonne surprise pour une majorité des
français qui étaient contre 1,7 qui
volent et oui si vous voulez vous ne
pouvez pas annoncer des mesures qui sont
quand même des mesures tout à fait
exceptionnel dans la vie quotidienne des
français depuis presque 70 ans voire
plus de 70 ans et ne pas donner un
moment donné un peu de mou qui
permettent tout simplement que les
français puissent accepter ces mesures
très contraignantes même ce sont des
mesures temporaires de quinze jours donc
il fallait vraisemblablement tenir
compte de l'état de l'opinion publique
et tu étais une opinion publique qui est
aujourd'hui pour le moins en tout cas
rétive à la politique d' emmanuel macron
pour faire passer ses mesures
contraignantes dans un contexte
d'urgence que l'on connaît son compte et
les mesures économiques qui l'annoncé de
soutien à l'économie qui sont tous le
coup elle dans la droite ligne de déjà
ce qu'il avait annoncé lors de son
intervention jeudi
mais encore une fois je crois que on est
dans une communication à deux étages il
faut être extrêmement prudent sur les
commentaires quand même en train de
faire et des observations que l'on peut
émettre sur son intervention parce que
ce qui va être important dans les heures
qui viennent ce sont les modalités
d'application des mesures qui sont
annoncées par le président de la
république et on voit quand même que
depuis maintenant je dis il ya une
répartition des rôles entre d'un côté le
président de la république donne le cap
et puis un premier ministre qui vient
ensuite dans un second temps très vives
et les mesures qui ont été annoncées par
le président de la république alors y
atteindre une mesure elle qui est
certaine ça ne vous a évidemment pas
échappé second tour des municipales
reporter quel est l'avis du communicant
sur cette question alors que s'est tenu
le premier tour dimanche dernier
alors outre le problème juridique que ça
va inévitablement aux et je crois que
finalement le président de la république
a réussi à obtenir le consensus des
forces politiques qui n'avaient pas pu
obtenir lors de son intervention jeudi
et d'ailleurs je dis on l'avait noté
qu'il s'était essentiellement appuyée
sur l'avis des scientifiques pour
justifier sa diffusion au de maintenir
le premier tour des élections
municipal on savait très bien que
finalement ce n'était pas une question
scientifique qui se posaient pour que se
trouvait tour soient tenues c'était tout
simplement qu'il n'avait pas réussi à
obtenir un compromis autour des
principales forces politiques qui
manifestement était opposé dans la
séquence que nous traversions sur voilà
un au tour des élections municipales
merci arnaud benedetti attend en chef de
la revue politique et parlementaire
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
france et on l'a